We don't have Lili.
Code's in the channel chat.
Yeah, I can add you in it if you need.
I just did that.
I pinged you in it, Lili.
Yeah.
Wait, can I rejoin?
Yeah, you can.
You should be able to.
Hey, Lili, scroll up.
As long as you don't leak the code.
Scroll up to the G1 Lobby B.
That channel.
That'll have the...
Okay, you know what?
I'll just message it to you.
That should be easier, maybe.
I feel so at peace right now.
Wait, Lili's not...
Is Lili in the Discord?
Did she leave?
Lili left the call.
Yeah, Lili left the call.
Yeah.
Yeah, where the hell is she now?
Lili left entirely.
Why is there two Dawkins?
Yeah, but I had to, like, relock.
They need to kick me.
Oh, I see.
Oh, Lili crashed.
Oh.
I don't think they can kick you, right?
Like, you have to leave yourself.
Yeah, but I did.
Didn't you just close the browser?
Well, I did, and then...
That's weird.
Never assumed it.
Well, you might have to remake, then.
Thank God, like, these games always have an intro, because I've never played this one before.
Right?
Wait, when I played it, it was, like...
It was...
My Discord stream goes black.
I was like, wait, Jackbox is not just QuickFlash?
.
What's wrong, Jack?
Wait, whenever I tab out, like, of the Discord stream, like, on my stream, it's just black.
Yeah, so...
Uh, if there's another full-screen application covering it, it'll turn it black.
Oh.
As to take priority.
I have a hardware acceleration.
Nobody say anything.
Oh.
I guess because, like, it's all anonymous, so you don't...
You can't, like, vote for each...
Whoa, whoa, what's that?
Whoa.
Oh, it's because they're making a new lobby.
Oh.
Hide this screen, everyone.
Hey, wait, remove...
Don't hide...
Hide this screen?
I think so.
Yeah, hide it so they don't see the code.
Oh, they just ended the stream.
Oh, okay.
Peace out.
Good call.
Welcome back, really.
This is going really well.
We love it.
At least we're here as a team.
That's the main thing.
We love it.
I've got some peppermint tea.
Oh.
Peppermint.
Ooh.
In a grommet mug.
All right, tournament's over.
Oh, new code.
New code.
There's a new room.
All right.
Can I just do it on my phone?
Yeah, you can.
You can.
But make sure to only join once.
Yes, ma'am.
Any more than that, and you're demoted.
Your team is completely just beyond.
Wait, who's on my team?
Kumi.
Doki.
True.
Tenzin.
I don't know.
What if, like...
You never told me who's on my team.
You're just...
You never asked.
You're like, you want to play.
Damn.
You never asked.
Because I need to know who I'm, like...
I need to know so I don't accidentally self-sabotage.
Damn.
Hurry up, demons.
Jack and Tenzin are on our team.
Mm.
The Kirby and the bear.
Okay.
I will make sure I don't sabotage ourselves.
Streams back up, everyone.
You can screen share again.
Okay.
Perfect.
And we're all happy about this.
We should have a code word so we vote for our team's...
Okay.
I'm clearing this.
There you are.
Let's go to HR.
Welcome back, Lily.
Lily?
Oh, no.
Lily's not back yet.
Okay, good call.
I had comps.
Is she mad at us?
Definitely mad at you.
She's been talking so much shit about you, Gumi.
Oh, my God.
It's because I played Blanka.
Yeah, 100%.
Ew, you played Blanka?
Oh, these fars- I was going to play Juri, man.
I was going to play Juri, but then CJ was like, Blanka's just like Yoshimitsu.
Is it true, though?
Yeah, he has a lot of gimmicks.
It is funky.
Yeah, she has the Blanka ball.
Oh, she has the Blanka ball.
I just remember how Blanka sounds like Donkey Kong.
And when he parries, he shakes ass.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He goes, .
Just like that.
Wait, how did they- Wait, sorry, can you go again?
How did they go again?
One more time?
.
Sounds like a dog that's about to bark.
A very sad dog.
Oh, apparently, Gumi, you're the VIP, Gumi.
You controlled the game.
Yeah, you know what to do Gumi.
You know what to do.
Is everybody... who are you missing?
It's just Lily, but I think she's having...
No, we're missing two.
Oh nevermind, now we're just playing.
Well, I was looking at OBS and the thingy's blocking it.
All right, I think we're just waiting on Lily now, right?
Yeah.
Um...
Okay.
All right.
Lily asked for five minutes, so everyone let's do icebreakers.
Okay.
I would rather die.
I don't want to talk anymore.
What does that even mean?
Welcome back to high school.
Okay.
Icebreakers are when you introduce yourself and a fun fact about yourself.
Yeah, like why don't you do like a two truths and one lies, everybody?
Hold on, let me drink some vodka real quick.
I can do it then.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, damn.
What the doki?
Simmer down.
Slurp, slurp.
Oh wait, I need messaging.
Oh.
Where are you messaging?
wake up wake up wake up Wake up Wakey wakey Wait I'll just...
Ocean man
Man, sorry for bringing up icebreakers...
I didn't know what killed the mood.
I really killed it.
It's time to break the ice.
Well, you just started.
He just brought, like, trauma.
Made everybody remember how bad high school was.
Alright, I just took a shot.
I'm ready.
What's the icebreaker?
Okay, I muted myself, guys.
Basically, for those who don't know, I got invited last minute.
Last minute.
I got invited...
Last minute to Twitch Rivals, Jackbox.
How do you make Jackbox competitive?
I asked the same question!
But basically, you get points, and then...
My most embarrassing moment?
One time in fourth grade, I thought I was in Treasure Show and I brought a large alligator doll and I sat in front of the entire class and everyone was getting ready for reading time, so I just sat there like an idiot with an alligator doll and the teacher didn't even tell me.
He just sat there looking at me and I realized, oh, it's reading time, so I had to put my alligator doll away.
What do they mean?
That teacher fucking hates you.
Honestly, fuck that teacher.
Was everybody else really loud?
I don't know if Sound Guy's awake at this time.
This was a very last minute stream.
I could turn people down.
I need to save the setting, though.
Who's next?
I'm gonna save this setting so I'll remember it before you see Jam Slam.
I'll turn people down, though.
My name is Tenzin.
My most embarrassing moment was I was at the water park at a birthday party and my crush was there, so I was trying to look cool and it was the first time I ever wore a two-piece.
I was in middle school, by the way, so normally I wore a one-piece but I was like, you know what, I'm gonna be a little...
I wanted to be a grown-ass bitch.
So I wore a two-piece and then I went to go surfing on this thingy.
It was like the fake waves where you surf on.
So my crush was there in line and I was like, I'll show him something.
Wait, no, please, Peter, wait!
No, no, no!
And then I surfed and then I fell off the thingy and I fell like, backwards, so the wave was crashing into my pants and then my pants fell off and then I had to stand up and pull out my pants.
Oh no!
You couldn't pull underneath the water?
You had to stand up.
No, the water was so...
I couldn't.
I couldn't stand up because then I would get knocked off my feet because of the waves.
So I mooned everybody.
You think he remembers?
100% remembers.
It's like 10 years has passed and he's died.
I'm a girl that don't moon me.
You made his day, probably.
Yeah, maybe.
Amazing memory.
Whoa!
He's like, damn, I didn't think I'd wake up and see ass today.
I'm starting in 3, 2, 1, starting!
Are we all here?
Yeah, we're all here.
Literally, everybody's here.
Which one's me?
Peter, that looks like you.
Oh, that's me.
Oh shit!
Wait, fuck you.
My eyes aren't that big.
I'm a teenager.
Wait, I'm a parent?
Who's the parent?
I'm a parent.
I wanna be a teenager.
Wait, why does Doki look so fucking cool?
Wait, no!
I look stupid!
Oh, fuck.
You're like a fucking Pixar mom.
Real shit.
Alright, who also has no idea how to play this game?
All of us.
I don't think people realize this game existed.
Alright.
That's why we're here.
This game came out three years ago.
Aww, look at you.
We're cute together.
Wow.
Oh, I'm a fucking...
I'm a boomer, I think.
I'm an adult.
No, I think you're a child.
Am I?
Wait, are the teams mixed?
I'm so confused.
Yes, let's see the tutorial.
Please, we need it.
You're going to see a list of tasks appear on your device.
You know, mow the lawn, muck out the gutters, stand in the garage, and sigh.
These are normal chores humans do every day.
No one knows why.
Complete these tasks and you'll earn points for the family score.
Keeping the family score high is your number one priority.
If you end the week with a low family score, you'll get a failing grade, and the boss downstairs will not be happy with you.
Ah, Satan.
I suggest you work together to do as many tasks as possible.
Some tasks require teamwork, so don't be afraid to yell when you need a hand.
But, there's also a prize for the individual that earns the most points.
They'll be rewarded with a human-style trophy to lord over the rest of the family.
The coveted world's bestest devil mug.
Last thing, tasks with this symbol are selfish tasks.
They don't help the family at all.
And doing too many causes an emergency that can be catastrophic to the family score.
However, they're worth a ton of points to those devilish enough to get away with them.
Just saying.
Okay.
I didn't retain any of that.
But like, what if I'm on the - but what if I'm on the enemy's family team?
Gronking?
I can't tell if we're all on the same team.
I think we're all on the same team.
Is this like, gooning?
What?
Huh?
That actually says this.
We're gonna find out soon.
I'm so confused.
What is this?
And doing all of them is the only way to get a perfect grade.
So don't screw them up.
Wait, what did they say?
In the minigame.
Oh.
Uh, shit.
Give me rice!
What do you need?
You need rice?
From the pantry.
Rice from the pantry.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Okay.
From the spice rack.
Soy beans from the pantry.
Eggs from the fridge.
Soy sauce from the spice rack.
So grab them quick.
Do you want it in the spice rack?
What is the spice rack?
What do you need in the spice rack?
I'm at the pantry.
What do I need at the pantry?
Sesame oil and nori.
Okay, I got it.
Nori.
And I need eggs from the fridge.
I got the items.
Okay, I got it.
Okay, we gotta watch about gronking.
Uh...
Looks like someone's being selfish.
What the fuck is happening?
I don't know.
I'm trying to learn about gronking.
Jack?
You can't do that.
Stop it.
What is gronking?
How do I look up?
No, I want to...
Yay!
What?
Oh, I see.
Stop Jack Cashew from being selfish.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
I'm...
I need earrings.
Oh, Lily!
It's pitchforks facing top right.
Up right, pitchforks.
Three.
Yay!
Can someone help me get to 60 beauty?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm doing an easy task.
Let's go to the den.
Let's search the den.
I'm searching the den.
Okay, I didn't find it.
I'm going to the basement.
Okay, it's not there.
Okay, I'm going to go through the trash.
I'm going through the trash.
Does anyone want to join me for breakfast?
We got it.
Nobody knows us.
What the hell is going on right now?
This is like full house.
I don't get it.
I don't know this game.
This is why nobody plays this game.
How can he tell?
Someone help him.
I just see people getting points.
You can't start this until everyone is here.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
I'm just doing...
Someone is doing a task.
What the fuck?
What is this?
The kitchen is on fire.
I'm sorry.
I caused an emergency.
Oh god.
How did I cause a fire?
What does that mean?
Wait, it's not me.
It says I'm not Doki Bird.
It wasn't me.
I get it.
I'm stopping Tenzin from being selfish, you selfish cunt.
Wait.
This is not a task?
Someone help me.
What is anti-Gronky?
Oh my god.
What am I listening to?
What is going on?
Oh my god.
He actually scores bad.
Stop.
Stop laughing juice.
He's being selfish.
No, no, I'm the best guy.
I'm the best fucking guy.
Guys, I might cause another fire.
Stop causing fires.
What the hell is your problem?
It's funny.
No, no, no.
It's a pink hat, a pink m'lady hat, light pink.
I hope you burn in hell.
Okay.
Is it?
No, is it this?
Okay, we need the sprinklers to be off.
Okay, end of this.
Okay, so it needs to be off.
With the dial and the... oh god, not again.
What is this?
Oh, it's Peter!
Peter's house on fire!
Get rid of all that, get rid of all that.
Okay.
Oh god, this family's going to hell.
I can't do shit!
Oh my god, Peter.
Okay, okay.
How could you do that?
I hope you rot in hell.
Pink hat, light pink hat.
We need the pink hat.
We're already in hell.
What do you mean?
We need the pink hat.
How is this what I'm doing?
Did you get it?
And the basement's flooded.
Who took a shit?
The basement's flooding.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
What is it?
Goomy, that's you!
Goomy, what did he eat?
I'm sorry!
Goomy!
Oh god, I didn't do anything!
Okay, we good?
I'm help.
Sprinklers.
I'm helping Doki.
Who drew on the fucking walls, man?
Okay, Doki, what is the setting?
Off, off, middle.
Middle.
Who wants to ride a bike?
Who wants to learn how to ride a bike?
Middle?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Who?
Peter did!
Guys, it wasn't me.
I have no idea who started the fire.
It was not me.
I swear to god.
Honey, help.
Haircut, please.
Please, honey, help.
Two blue earrings.
What?
Golden moon earrings.
Two earrings.
Crescent.
Four moons.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Goomy, what is it?
Oh, Tenzin.
Um.
What am I supposed to do?
It's one short graph, one long.
I don't know.
I did it.
The fourth one.
DTD.
And then Lopinus.
The second one is empty, empty, full.
And the third one is first notch.
Alright, I'm not doing this anymore.
Alright, I'm helping someone else.
What the fuck?
I don't know what's happening.
What do you want me to do, Goomy?
I don't know.
I'm not helping anymore.
Why do people stop me?
Did I do something bad?
I don't know how to ride a bike.
It isn't easy to ride a bike, kiddo.
Just hop on by swiping up.
You need to swipe up, kiddo.
Okay, Lily.
I'll help you.
Oh, god damn it.
Fucking hell.
Oh, no.
I can't do this.
It's only day one.
Tenzin said so many of the things I was doing.
I literally got nothing done.
I don't know what's going on.
I have to fly four times in day one.
You're supposed to read Meet the Green?
Wait.
We didn't even go halfway there.
We did Gronk stuff, though.
We did Gronk.
Who the fuck was Gronking on company time?
I'm not a Gronk once or twice.
I think we may need to go to family therapy.
Peter, Peter, Peter.
It wasn't me.
It's all Grady.
Wait.
Did we all fail?
I just did my task and then it said, oh, Peter got greedy and I have to go out to fire three times.
Oh, no.
Okay.
That's Tenzin.
It wasn't me, though.
I saw a lot of Goomy and Peter.
I'm not going to lie.
Yeah, me too.
I just see them.
Jack, how about stop looking, then, you pervert?
What the hell?
Wait.
Stop doing something illegal.
It's okay.
They took our scores.
They took our scores already.
They got it.
Oh, okay.
I don't even know what our scores even was.
Did we win?
What was our score?
Oh, shit.
Wait.
I got second place?
Okay.
Let's go.
Wait.
Who got first?
I missed it.
What place was that?
I got third place?
That's so messed up.
Wait.
My team is ass.
Oh, whatever.
You guys are fucking garbage.
Everyone on my team had half my score.
Listen.
Don't listen to him.
He doesn't need it.
You guys are terrible.
Lily, you won't be on our team.
We'll never call you ass.
Lily, don't listen to him.
Lily, remember, I helped you when nobody else helped you, Lily.
Are you guys serious?
Can I switch teams?
Can I go somewhere else?
Wait.
You can't say that when you had the lowest score.
Are you kidding me?
No.
Every time I did something, it said, oh, Peter got greedy.
Put out the fire.
That is true.
It did keep saying Peter got greedy and then set the house on fire.
I'm going to be so fucking real with you guys, I don't even know what that means.
I don't know what I was greeting.
You were clicking the red cast so you get extra points.
Yeah.
You get extra points by...
Wait, so why did your own teammates stop you?
Well, that's funny.
I have no idea.
But look at their scores.
Garbage.
You stopped me.
I didn't stop you.
I didn't know what I was doing.
You tried my best to raise you.
I wanted to win as a family, so I stopped everyone.
So clearly you guys know what I'm talking about.
Okay, but like, who won?
Did we win?
Who did we win?
We won.
Thank God.
Okay.
Your collective scores are way higher than ours.
So I'm assuming you won that one.
Yeah.
Like, all of you had at least 3k.
My team didn't even break two and a half.
Okay.
Well...
Listen, it's tough.
It's tough, Emily.
Stop me with Doki.
Come on, man.
I am so down.
Honestly, do it.
Please.
Retreat.
We don't want to...
Look at what you've done.
You broke this family apart.
I want a divorce.
I asked to be born into this family, okay?
You and everyone else.
All right.
We're just dropping.
Hey, good job, team.
I'm so happy we worked so well together.
Yay.
We tried our best, team.
We gave it our best shot.
I hate you.
Shut up.
You've got a Gd for f**king your ass.
You don't even know how to do chores.
You don't even know how to make money.
Fucking, fucking, fucking, fucking.
That is crazy.
You're probably the weirdest guy I ever know...
like I've met.
You...
you mean that?
Yes.
Guys, there's a new lobby code, but you guys are not in our lobby.
Yeah.
You guys have to leave.
Jeter's team move up.
Yeah, yeah.
You got to go lobby A.
What did you just say?
You don't mean that.
I was hacked.
All right.
I hate you all.
I agree with him though.
Goodbye.
Bye.
Alright, GG!
Bye, guys!
Hey, good job, teammates!
I'm proud of you guys!
We did it!
Just to be clear, I got first, right?
Yeah, but it's a team score, so it doesn't matter.
But you got points for us.
I think you get extra money for being first, though, in general, right?
You looked so beautiful in the video, the little Twitch Rivals thing I saw.
That's so sweet!
So, does that mean you guys are going to throw for me, Goobie, or what's up?
No.
You don't understand what we just went through.
Did you guys know what was happening, either?
It was insane.
Actually, you guys have an LM over there, and...
Oh, God.
Who won on the other game?
How is there first to eighth?
There's more than eight...
How is there first to eighth for this?
Doki, stop asking questions you won't want answers to.
There's four teams.
Like, I don't want to...
There's eight people in one lobby.
Oh, so we're playing against each other.
But we're also on the same team, Doki.
Wake up!
That's surprising for a team!
Listen.
Just relax.
Have fun.
I'm so relaxed.
Everyone, the code is up.
You're probably going to lose anyways.
That's crazy.
I'm going to hand that one off to you, actually.
What's this?
This is Quiplash.
Okay, we all know Quiplash.
Alright, so we're leading up against each other now, right?
Yes.
There's no...
There's no team points here.
There's no pandering here.
Yeah.
This one, we don't need to show our stream, right?
No, no.
I'll let you just share the games from here.
You have to show the admin screen, not your own.
Got it.
I didn't show my own at all on my stream.
He hated me.
Okay.
Oh!
That's...
Okay, that makes sense.
No wonder we were confused.
Hey, Rudy.
Wait, we were supposed to show our screen last game?
Yeah.
I mean, you can.
I didn't.
I was too lazy for that.
We're not showing the Discord one?
Not this one.
You're showing Discord.
We are not showing the Discord.
Now you show the Discord one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You show the Discord one.
Yes.
Oh, you know...
Guys, where's the code?
It's in lobby B.
It's in G2.
Yeah.
Oh, thanks.
Okay.
We're missing...
Now we show the Discord one is what you're saying.
Your...
We've always had to show the Discord...
Yvonne, I will ask you...
Huh?
Yeah.
But we're supposed to show the last one.
Last one?
Yeah.
Well...
It was optional.
We're great streamers, guys.
Cool.
We got that.
We're going to Falling Directions.
Yeah.
I agree.
Okay.
We're all in.
Relax and relax.
Yippee.
What are you missing?
This music is so funky.
We're all here.
We just need the...
Oh.
Oh, it's OK to start.
Are they, like, streaming RPO?
Are they streaming this?
Is that why it's taking a bit?
You're confusing me, Toki.
Stop!
Oh, god.
Who's making that sound?
I'm already done.
I think it's Toki.
There is no way.
Uh...
Roo!
That's how Blanca sounds.
Have you practiced Blanca today, Gumi?
Hold on, I'm receiving a message.
Oh?
Whoa!
I can't see my cursor anymore.
How do I fix this?
I think you said...
Shut up.
I don't know what else the message said.
Man...
I hate when a pistachio doesn't have an opening for you to open it.
Whoa, pistachio.
Use your teeth.
Get in the cracker.
Oh, okay.
Pistachio.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Ow, it's really hard.
Pistachio?
How do you say it?
It's too hard.
You crack me up.
I can't do it.
I'm gonna break my teeth.
I took these pistachios.
From the karaoke place.
Dude, you're stealing now?
We paid for them.
They're so good.
We paid, right?
Wait, from when we went?
Yeah.
Bro, that was like a week ago.
I know.
My drunk ass brought them home.
Classic, Yvonne.
Stealing pistachios.
What a classic.
You're really good.
Who's swapping around?
Sorry.
The owners?
No, it's okay.
Do whatever you want.
What if we were supposed to start now, but we never realized?
No, I have the discord open.
They would tell us.
I trusted Ruby.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I muted myself.
There's too many people.
I thought...
Did you guys see icebreakers up there too?
I legitimately thought that we'd be in our own voice chat.
Yeah, we talked about the most embarrassing moment in our lives.
10 to 9 win.
Cause we are the worst.
I didn't realize we were combined with the other team.
I'm like, that's a lot of people in the...
Why is it every time I mute myself to talk to you guys, everybody starts talking?
I think it's our icebreaker when we just flamed Ellum.
Oh.
That's a really good icebreaker.
I thought it was pretty good.
Every time.
Which I saw the clip of after someone showed me and it was totally unprompted.
Unprompted?
What was it?
No, they asked me.
They didn't ask you who the worst player was?
Oh.
What?
What are you saying?
Wait, who got lost?
I don't think you're the worst player.
They didn't even ask you that.
You said it.
It's the crazy part.
Oh.
Our team is falling apart from the inside.
Listen, guys, this is what family game night is all about.
You know?
It is.
What's the friendly...
That's true.
Between the two of us.
Banter.
What's the fun?
Family game is all about helping your family get...
You would get just as much blame if we were not on stream.
That doesn't make it better.
It's like my mom.
I feel like it's like my mom.
Like my mom's here with us.
I think they get blamed way more off stream.
No.
If that makes you feel any better.
I like imagining Mi-young just being like, yeah, it's pretty hot today.
I woke up early.
Yvonne's our worst player.
Yeah.
That was...
That's her return.
It was.
Yeah.
She asked like a completely different question and Mi-young goes, oh, I thought you asked who her worst player was.
Not even the same.
I thought you were asking who the weakest link on our team would be.
And oh, I don't want to say names, but I think you'd be a ball on it.
I don't want to say names, but...
Listen.
I'll prove you guys all wrong one of these days.
I feel like that just makes it like what you do in the game very memorable.
Like that's what I remembered most out of our practice run.
Yeah.
I think I might just get one more ball.
Is twitch rivals PG 13.
Definitely not rated R.
Yeah.
This is a nasty game.
So...
Are they releasing a naughty pack for jack box?
Yeah.
You want to play it Doki?
They gave me a free code.
I have it.
I also have it.
Yeah.
It's called After Hours or something.
They're releasing an R18 jack box?
Oh my god.fold.
You're allowed to stream it too, they said.
As long as you put your stream on mature.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't even know what kind of games were in it.
They were just like, do you want free code?
And I was like, I love free stuff.
Yeah, sure.
Don't care.
We should have been streaming that game instead.
I don't think they want that.
No, they haven't said it yet.
They're typing.
Oh, we can start.
Let's go.
We can start now.
Starting in 3, 2, 1.
Wow, that's what I said.
Woohoo.
Quick blush.
Surely we play honorably.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
And before you ask, no, I'm not related to the Schmitzensteins who live down the street from you.
I was curious, yeah.
One.
But it's round one.
Two prompts will show up on your device.
Answer them however the mood strikes.
You'll go head to head against someone else.
Everybody else's clever answer and everybody else will decide which one they like better.
Points are awarded based on the percentage of people who went for your answer.
So make them count.
Is anyone else sweating?
No.
I'm really nervous.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait, is there audience participation for this one?
I'm not sure.
The code's on the top right.
Yeah, there's a code there.
All I see is one moderator.
Oh, there isn't.
My chat said there's no audience participation.
I'm done.
Am I the only one?
Wait.
What is a safety quip?
What do you get for safety quips?
Safety.
Uh, the safety quip just gives you like a random generated answer.
Oh.
Wouldn't it be funny if you win with that?
Also, everyone, they said keep the answer safe for work.
Oh.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Tenzin?
Wait, what happened?
Oh, wow.
I hope this doesn't say it.
Aweeeeee.
A black smith forge?
There's nothing wrong with those ones.
Ah.
Oh.
The safety quip.
That's a safety quip.
I couldn't think of anything PG, so I used the safety quip.
I didn't work.
The one with the .
Is it a with the .
You're a five year old.
She's right.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel like they should have told us that it should be PG earlier.
We've been talking about this for like 20 minutes.
That was crazy.
How are half of you not voting at all?
I voted!
I would like to apologize.
The first answer got me stun locked.
Yeah, me too.
What are you guys doing?
What is going on?
Oh my god!
Wait, can you get disqualified?
Yvonne!
I'm racking in the points!
I did my job!
Yvonne, we gotta have a talk.
Tell me I'm wrong.
What the fucker?
What is this?
I didn't vote.
I just, I couldn't.
I don't understand.
You're not allowed.
Penn, do you want to explain?
If you want to be a supermodel, squat down on the runway and then blank.
If you want to be a supermodel, stretch to the end of the ramp.
The bust out of your face is definitely a safety cue.
A safety cue.
Yeah, yeah.
What?
That is not...
I thought it was a safety cue.
Damn, you suck, Yvonne.
That was not a safety one.
It wasn't?
You're a supermodel and you don't get it?
That was both.
That was clever.
I think that's someone's personal pet peeve.
The mirror?
I don't know.
I'm assuming that's what people would say.
Damn, you guys still like the mirror, huh?
Wait, what does...
It's in the intro.
What does the mirror mean?
I love that for you, Doki.
Wait, what is that?
Is that the newest word?
I abstain.
What is this?
Oh, there's only one right answer here.
That's crazy.
And that was not it.
That was a safety quip?
Thank you, Matt.
Yes.
Abusing the system.
Um, the worst thing to be inscribed...
Wait, welcome home feels pretty good.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I wrote something that would disgust me and make me want to not enter the home.
It is kind of close to welcome home.
Yes, that's what I was going for.
Thank you.
Yep, got you.
But that's what makes it good.
Why nobody voted on it?
Because we want that.
Yeah, because it's a good one.
Yeah.
We're taking the word back.
Oh, okay.
Damn.
Oh.
Hey, high five.
My fault.
I guess I'm the best.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, they're doubled.
We were only sandbagging the first one, right?
Yeah.
We can be actually funny, right?
Like, all of us can actually be funny.
So, are we keeping this PG or...?
Yeah, PG.
Wait, for a safety quip, do they like automatically submit an answer for you?
Yeah.
So, you don't even have to see what they wrote.
Time.
Don't forget your safety quips.
I guess it's technically PG.
If you have a PG mind.
True.
Moderation is still in progress.
So, if you got...
Yeah.
You think?
My answer could be PG.
Okay.
If there's moderation, that means they're vetting our answers.
Therefore, the last ones were okay.
Yeah.
Wait.
That means...
Aren't you the moderator?
Someone was being weird.
No, no, no.
I'm just a VIP.
Oh.
Wait.
What happened?
What?
Let's do this.
Okay.
I think my answer got vetted then.
It automatically got vetted.
It automatically stumped me when they said PG.
Everybody forgets that one episode.
I'm gonna say...
What?
The wrong one is Yvonne's.
That's not me.
I didn't vote.
I'll vote for it.
Wow.
That was a safety quip.
I've never watched Friends before.
Me too.
I'm just like...
Stand-up comedy Netflix special.
Okay.
Now it gets real.
Pick your favorite.
That's PG, right?
It's just...
Yeah.
Technically, it's PG.
It's like when they drop a joke in like a Pixar movie.
Yeah.
When you...
Because you're laughing so hard, you know?
That's PG.
That was funny.
So the tears come out and make you wet.
The tears.
Yeah.
It's the tears.
I get it.
You like this.
So you can act.
Yeah.
I don't talk to women in real life, so...
That is a crazy safety quip.
What on earth?
Do you lose points for not voting?
Oh.
No.
I don't think so.
Oh.
I could be wrong though.
Actually, I have no idea.
I don't know why I said I don't think so.
But I think you get points for voting.
Yeah.
These both...
I don't know.
Are these both safety quips?
No.
Don't tell her that.
She's going to abstain from voting.
They're both safety quips?
I didn't know.
Okay.
Firm handshakes.
The law and order sound should play whatever blank.
Dun dun.
Whatever.
What?
Okay.
That's a vote for me.
What's...
What?
What's the sound?
Bum bum.
Oh no.
Abe.
The real reason sharks won't go on land.
Okay.
It gets real.
Pick your favorite.
Oh.
That was a good one.
Yeah.
And the people that get it, get it.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I love Sharknado.
Tengu was cocking up, but she was laughing at the wrong one.
I want to speak to your manager.
What?
And Mel, pick your favorite.
I think that was a safety one.
The first one's a safety quip for sure.
Yeah.
I'm going to vote for the safety.
I like it a lot.
Sometimes the AI is funnier.
Yeah, it is.
Sure that one's safety.
That's crazy.
No way to say thank you.
Got it.
Thank you.
Okay.
You reached the second question.
So pretty safe.
You know what, that was a good one.
Moving right along, the last thing an art museum security guard wants to find at night.
Calm.
All right, people.
It's voting time.
That is insane.
You guys are crazy.
You guys, that's PG, right?
That's...
They're just casting spells.
Like, come on.
Yeah.
It's...
A magic wand!
It's like a magician, right?
Wow, that's it for round 2?
Wait, there was a magic wand earlier?
Let's see your scores!
Yep, your mom's.
Oh!
Ow, it hurts down here!
I guess I'm still the best.
It's okay, it's triple the points!
Yeah, triple!
This is where it all matters!
This is when you can actually be funny.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you guys were sandbagging.
Yeah, we were just sandbagging, guys, right?
I'm gonna actually write a funny response.
Through triplash?
Okay, okay.
And by write, I mean I'm doing a safe...
What?
I'm not sweating this way.
Okay.
Bikini.
Chicken suit.
Huh?
Oh, where's the safety quip?
Where's the safety quip?
I'm trying to brain blast so hard.
Oh, no.
There's no safety.
What do you do?
Do something.
Okay, my answer's not funny.
I just, I didn't know how to deal with this.
Same.
Awful, but I can't...
There's too many stuff we have to write down.
I can't go beyond one.
Mine was so lame!
So bad!
That's so bad.
I'm gonna cry.
The one time we need a safety quip.
It doesn't give it to us.
I know!
Wait, who are we?
Oh, it's the moderator.
I was like...
Who wrote something crazy?
Confess.
Who did it?
It's, I know it's not me.
My, my answer's dumb.
My answer's dumb!
It's so PG.
Three odd outfit choices for a horror movie slasher to wear.
Oh.
Now it's time to vote for your favorite.
What is a kissing emoji outfit?
Yeah, what is that?
I don't know, but I'm into it.
Like, a suit with kissing emojis printed on it?
I'm going with my head cannon.
I'm just voting for the points.
I need the extra points.
Three signs that your neighbor is upset with you.
Oh.
W.
What?
The W is funny!
I don't know, like you're all laughing at me, but you're not laughing at me.
Yeah, I voted!
I voted!
We're laughing at you, not with you.
The W carried your answer.
Whoa!
I mean, that's pandering.
I would be like the boss, right?
Wait, why is Broden in there with those two?
No, no, I felt like you need some height.
Wow, okay.
Okay, wow.
Wow.
Okay.
I don't know what Dimir is, so I can't vote for that.
Nobody explain Dimir.
This crowd doesn't know Dimir, man.
They don't get it.
They're not on the talk, bro.
No, we do.
They're not on the talk.
It's not my fault.
I hate to say it.
No, it's been too... it's past date, man.
It's expired.
Damn, Abe, you went for the Christmas.
Wow!
Thank you, Goo.
We appreciate you.
Thank you!
Yay, yay, yay!
That's crazy.
We did it!
Individually!
Wow, Blank Smith Forge.
We did it!
Yay!
Wow, the VIP won.
It could've... was it rigged?
Rigged?
The question mark?
What?
I just have to mention...
It's okay, literally.
I'll make sure it's not rigged.
Seems somebody was pandering.
Woo, no laughs!
Yeah!
Fourth!
Alright, what's the next game?
Oh, we're going Trivia Murder Party.
Against LM's team.
Okay, that's a team game, right?
Or is it individual?
No, it's still... everything's individual if you think about it.
Unless you yell out the answer.
Wait, they're all individual?
Oh, that's true!
Everyone whisper the answers into your teammates' ear.
Why are we in a team, then?
Say it, Quirk.
Whoever wins will also help their team get further in the leaderboard.
And then someone will be really loud and yell out the answer.
Oh!
Yeah, Doki, you would be great at that.
Oh, wait!
There's no rules against chat.
She knows.
Doki, please!
Please!
This isn't you.
It is you, though, actually.
Okay, I'll make sure I won't look at... I won't have my face turned to chat.
I'll give it five seconds before I look.
Guys, don't worry.
There's definitely a stream delay.
Guys, I won't use Google.
Wait, so this is gonna be... this is gonna be... whose chat is smarter?
Yeah, it's basically whose chat is smarter.
I don't feel like I have time to Google.
Like, these things are quick.
There's a delay.
Yeah, there's a delay.
So, like, if you just wanted to say out random answers, like, it's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Show how smart you are, you know what I mean?
Yeah, guys, you guys love backseating, right?
This is your chance.
Exactly.
Whichever chat... yeah, we're here... it's not, like, whichever streamer's smarter is whichever chat's the best backseater.
We're about to get tagged.
Yeah, you know how you always get banned for backseating?
This is the one time this is your job.
You can backseat your streamer.
Yeah.
Anyone else's chat saying we're doomed or, like, is everyone else's chat on it?
Mine's saying gg easy.
They said, so we get a cut?
You get recognition from the streamer.
I will read your name out if you give me the right answer.
Uh...
It'll be that easy.
No, you guys... yeah, you guys get a cut, alright?
Exposure, you know?
For the exposure, guys.
Are we still lobby B?
No, we're in lobby A, buddy.
No!
Let me hit them.
I don't wanna move.
Like, I don't move!
Nice.
It's just moving?
It's just a scroll and a click away.
That's too much.
Yeah, that is.
Oh.
Okay.
And then I gotta just do trivia after?
Sorry, Ka-chan.
Let's push the button.
Do we push the button?
Oy, oy, oy.
That was, like, the icebreaker.
Is that the...
How are they still...
How are they still playing their game?
Like, it's not a lot.
Everything's timed, like, exactly the same.
They're still thinking about their answers?
No, I think they're also done.
Okay, I was gonna say.
How are they still there?
It's like 60 seconds.
They're in an ad break.
Oh, they get an ad break.
Oh.
Okay, it's time to move.
Okay.
Hello.
I heard that was, like, Mafia or something.
Oh.
Hello.
That's me wiping your bald head on the floor.
What?
I'm not even bald.
I'm not even balding.
Not yet.
I'm not balding.
Guys.
Please don't know who I am.
Wig.
Oh, that's me grabbing it to the top of your head.
I have no idea.
What do you mean you carry balls all the time?
What do you mean?
Yeah, I need some balls my bro.
Maybe it's fucking not gross.
It's your fault.
Whoa.
Lobby's almost out.
Wait is lobby code?
Lobby code's out.
Okay, who wants to be VIP?
So, I don't think I've met everyone in this lobby, but nice to meet you, I'm Josh.
Pleasure to meet you guys.
Hi, guys.
If I haven't met you... Hi, Jack.
Okay.
My name's Jack, too.
What's up, man?
Oh, wait.
You, too?
My name's Jack, as well.
What the hell up, Josh?
How do you know it's Josh?
It's my middle name.
I'm Josh Jack Bingo.
You didn't know that?
Wait, did you just dox yourself?
No, actually, my middle name's actually Max.
What's up?
What's your mom's maiden name?
Yeah, what is it?
And also the name of your first dog?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
And what elementary school you went to?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What was your teacher's first name?
That was your teacher's first name?
Yeah.
First car model, too?
Oh, God.
They're asking all the big questions.
The thing is, I wouldn't end up answering that.
Like, I genuinely would end up answering that.
I wouldn't even think about it.
And all of a sudden, I'm having to change my name.
Maybe that's how I don't become a Bingo anymore.
I dox myself entirely, and then my entire family's forced to change the name.
The lineage ends with me, and then I become something cool.
Whoa, wait, good job, everyone.
We're all in here.
Does that movie start now?
They make you wait.
They're like, yeah.
Oh, God.
I'm hungry.
I want some chicken wings.
Oh, you should go and get food right now.
They won't be ready to start yet when you come back.
So don't worry.
No, no, no.
You should go.
Go get food.
Guys, I'm eating some chips.
I hope we start the game now.
Anyone want to play Roblox?
I've never played Roblox before.
Wait, you've never played Roblox before?
No, I haven't.
Wait, no.
You can see me eating.
It's crazy.
Look at that.
It's like I'm keeping my purity.
Guys, I got not one, but two baby bells.
What's a baby bell?
You know, I knew you would get cheese.
It's a cheese wheel.
I got a cheese wheel.
Are you just eating the cheese like that?
Oh, no.
Okay, trust me.
This isn't even back in the day.
I would happily now eat cheese from the block like a rat.
Oh, my God.
What the heck?
You should do that.
It's literally from the block.
Is your heart okay?
I could die at any moment.
It was the last time you got a checkup.
It's been a while, it's been a while.
Now you're coming to America, dude.
Good luck.
Yeah, shit, bro.
That would be $5,000.
For them to touch your... never mind.
Touch your... finish the sentence.
What did they want?
The doctor touched me.
Make sure you cough, Alan.
Make sure you cough.
What the...
Wait, are you my doctor?
I'm down.
Free checkup.
That's why I go right there.
Gotta make sure you're healthy, big man.
What kind of chips you got?
I'm not balding.
Dude, I've never had Cheetos before.
I'm unmuted.
Wait, I had Cheetos today, too.
I was talking to chat.
I didn't know I was unmuted.
There's nothing wrong.
We can discuss it.
Yeah, I got some hot Cheetos.
Oh, hot Cheetos.
Never mind.
Is that good crisp?
You like that red 40?
Yeah.
I got a Mulch Max with my...
What is a Mulch Max?
Hey, Doki, you stream on YouTube, right?
No, I'm on Twitch today because it's Twitch Rivals.
Oh, true.
Oh, I was gonna say it'd be crazy if you won the SF tournament at TwitchCon.
Oh, yeah.
I don't even go there.
Yeah, that'd be kind of funny.
When are we gonna start the game?
It's time to go, guys.
It's an ad break.
They gotta get their ad revenue.
Yeah, the Myth Walker.
They ran like 10 ads.
Give us a sec.
I just wanna play trivia, guys.
I'm so good at it.
You mean your chat's so good at it.
Sorry, Doki.
Are you cheating?
You're a cheater.
Reporting.
Oh, jokes on you.
It's not in the rules.
I'm gonna cheat my ass off.
This is the moment your backseaters can shine.
Yeah.
Can you give me a fun fact?
Are you asking me to chat?
I'm not asking you, not my chat.
I'm asking you.
Can we get a fun fact real quick?
I'm practicing right now.
Mosquitoes have 47 teeth.
What?
Wait, what does?
Mosquitoes have 47 teeth.
Oh.
They have teeth?
That's what I'm saying.
It's like these little sharp edges, but people call them teeth.
Don't they have a spout?
A spout.
They have little teeth on them, like the little sharp thingies.
That's how they suck your blood.
Oh yeah, they have to bite the skin.
They bite the skin.
Oh.
Australia has wires in the moon?
Okay.
That's a fun fact.
I'm gonna be sorry with you.
I thought Australia was a small island until about a month ago.
I'm just saying.
Technically it is an island.
It is an island.
It's a small island.
I thought you could get from one side to the other pretty quick.
I didn't realize it was a whole thing.
It was a whole concept island.
No, that's New Zealand.
Consonant?
Can you actually name them all in biggest to largest continents or no?
Biggest to smallest?
Go for it.
I don't think I can even name them all.
You can't name them all?
No, you can do this.
Biggest one.
Definitely Africa.
Wrong.
Great try.
Asia.
Beautiful.
Okay, there you go.
Next one's Africa.
We have Africa.
Ellen, please use your chat to help you.
Phone a chat right now.
We have North America after that, right?
Correct.
Then we're going to South Africa.
South America.
South America is not a continent.
You just said Africa.
We're going to Australia.
No, no.
We're going to Europe.
Yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Then you're Australia.
Nope.
Great try.
You know, there's like...
There's another country with Australia and it's called something else.
Do you remember when you first discovered the Milky Way, Ellen?
Yeah, like the chocolate bar.
Yeah, it was great.
No, no, no.
The Milky Way and the Big Dipper.
Yeah, the chocolate bar.
You learned about this a year ago.
The Big Dipper is a chicken wing.
Okay.
I just met him.
I just met Ellen now and I know he definitely did not retain any information.
This isn't you.
No, okay.
One of them.
Antarctica.
Antarctica, guys.
Come on.
Yes.
How many times did I look at you?
And then that's all of them.
No more after that.
No, Australia after that one.
Australia after that one.
New Zealand isn't a continent, you idiot.
No, it's not.
There's another one near Australia?
No.
What?
It's because you keep naming Australia.
And I was like, if you're going to name Australia, you've got to think about New Zealand and think about your answer.
Wait, how is there another one?
Where is it?
You missed Antarctica.
You missed that one.
How is the other one now?
You're good now.
You're locked in.
Look at you.
You did it.
I'm surprised you got Asia, to be honest, and Africa.
Okay.
I'll be real.
I learned about continents a couple of years ago, but I thought Africa was a country until...
You learned about continents a couple of years ago?
What are they teaching you over there in the UK?
I've explained this one before, but basically, hit me out.
When you're in school, it gets to a certain level where people assume you know information.
For example, I didn't know my vowels up until maybe three years ago, but until then, everyone assumes you know them, so no one tells me because they're like, well, obviously, he knows, right?
Are you acting?
Is this like a persona?
I'm always crying.
I know what vowels are now.
Is this a bit?
A-I-O-U.
A-I-O-U and sometimes Y.
Sometimes Y, you know?
Guys?
So, anyone else on anything stupid?
No, just me.
Every day I wake up.
Oh, guys are ready.
We're ready to go.
I'm starting it, everyone.
It's time to start the game.
Good job, everyone.
We did it.
Iced out.
I'm so happy for everyone here.
What are the vowels?
A-I-O-U and sometimes Y on occasion.
I only know that because of Wordle taught me that.
You learned from Wordle?
You learned because Wordle became a streamer game and that's how you learned vowels?
Yes.
So, I learned how to spell humor as well.
Oh.
Yeah.
True story.
You guys spelled the word humor weird.
I pronounced it Hummer and it ended up on a livestream fails site.
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, team.
Let's lock in.
I need to up the game volume.
Here we go.
Let's do this, let's go.
You know,
last game.
I was about to say that.
First game is this.
This is our time.
So, we're going to play this.
And it's a while- How long do we have until the final game?
You have 2 seconds.
I have no idea what this is.
I think it's in Sudan, right?
Yes!
I was gonna guess that.
Guys, we have one of the smarter chats.
Good job, guys.
I thought we were playing trivia.
It is trivia.
I'm dying?
Oh, I know who's dying here.
Me, for sure.
Oh, I selected you.
Let me tell you that.
Wait, you selected Wig too?
If we select together, we both can get $100.
Guys, if we all select Wig, we can get $100.
He's in the cold.
I've never met you before.
Hello.
Have you seen this cat?
It has the eyes of a cat that has seen far too much and answers to the name Muffin.
What the hell does that mean?
It has been missing for five years.
What am I typing?
Am I supposed to be doing something right now?
No, you're just supposed to listen to it, Wig.
Because it's a riddle.
Time's up.
Oh, fuck me, man.
Yeah, you were supposed to type it.
Oh, dude.
Bro, I typed the whole thing out.
And I deleted it.
No, I deleted it too.
$100, let's go.
God, it's for joking sabotage.
That's insane.
You just killed your own teammate, you sicko.
We're in the lead, guys.
We're in the lead.
I got $100, though.
Just more see-through.
Get clean, and you just might steal someone else's life force and win the game.
Oh, jeez.
The two Jacks.
Yeah, both Jacks died.
I guess we just hate Jacks.
Oh, wait, that's a...
Let's try another one.
Where do Archie, Jughead, Betty, and Veronica...
Oh, I know this without having to.
What game is this?
I actually read the...
What video game is this?
Who are these people?
What is that?
I actually read the Archie comics.
I read this comic, but I actually forgot.
This is a comic?
Yeah.
Archie, Jughead, Betty, Veronica, Reggie, Stilton, Moose.
It's an American comic.
Oh, is this about the Nemo's, man?
I know the lore.
I didn't get that right.
How did I even...
What is this?
What's chocolate?
Wait, what is it?
It's Pop's Cocktail Shop.
Yeah, they always go to the Pop's.
What the fuck?
Ooh.
Huh?
I'll kill the player with the lowest score.
Oh.
And you die instead.
Think about statistics, everyone.
Think about statistics.
Oh, I have to roll?
Alright.
Roll!
I can keep rolling.
I'm rolling.
Roll!
Oh, my God.
No, I'm sticking.
I'm rolling.
Oh, no!
I had no choice.
I had to get above, like, because if you're the lowest score, you lose anyway, right?
So...
True.
Oh, that's true.
I had 18, so I was gonna die no matter what, so I either roll or die anyway.
Yeah.
True.
You're a genius.
Mad bitches don't die, Hyun.
Like...
Yes, ma'am.
We might be zero, but we're not...
Oh, I don't know my cardinal directions, guys.
This is...
I need help.
I don't know, like...
What the fuck does this mean?
I don't know my cardinal directions.
I don't know.
I'm gonna guess.
Right?
I have no idea.
I chose West, guys.
West, guys.
Clearly West.
Okay.
Lock it in.
If he says West, I choose East.
West.
No, I chose West, too.
You're an idiot.
JK, I chose East.
Just kidding.
One of you guys are typing now?
Not one of you guys?
Not...
No, sure, dude.
Hey, Brazilian dragoons, thank you.
Oh, God.
Oh, loud.
Any dragoons that wanna help me a little?
Oh.
Go ahead, everyone.
Go ahead.
I got the curse?
Okay.
Ooh.
Bucket.
If each of us choose one of them...
I'm choosing four, so don't choose four.
I choose...
I chose six.
We have to split it up.
I locked in four.
Please have you guys save me.
Please have you save me.
I think you're fine.
I totally didn't choose the one you're right above.
Bro, I mean, it's just all...
It's just up to you.
If you're a gamer, then you just...
Oh.
Yeah.
You literally...
Oh.
Oh, come on, dude.
Bro.
You guys...
Childish...
That was just one.
Bye.
TehZin.
TehZin's safe, TehZin.
Thank you so much.
He's safe.
The body grab...
Take it.
Please do, TehZin.
Oh, get down.
That is instant.
I'll never forget this.
She'll win for you.
She'll always win.
Oh, and you guys are all dead.
No, you got me, bro.
Only the ladies are alive, though.
The only was the human boss.
You got this.
Oh.
Oh, team women!
Let's go!
Let's go, girls!
Okay, I actually don't know.
I don't know what the capital city of Canada is.
I don't pay attention.
You're literally Canadian.
I know!
Yes, I am!
It's Montreal, guys!
I don't pay attention!
It's geography!
Dude, how is it Oshawott?
That doesn't even make sense.
Oshawott.
That is Oshawott.
What the fuck is that?
Wait, I've got answers.
No idea.
No idea, dude.
If y'all got this one right, you're cheating.
I don't care.
That's insane.
I was a theater kid.
I was a theater kid in high school.
You were a theater kid?
I'm just passing you!
Why is that corpsey?
How did you all know that?
I thought that just seemed like...
We're cracked.
We're actually cracked.
Because we killed the character off.
I'm gonna come back and win.
Yeah.
Holy Christ.
Wait, are you guys...
But we all got it right.
Oh, we're...
Yeah, it's you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Take as much money as you want.
Take it all.
Take it all, kid.
Take the most money or the least money and you'll be sorry.
I guarantee you, ends and dies this time.
Um...
I put a really cool answer.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Gumi...
Who's alive?
Gumi and Doki.
Me.
Yeah.
Those are my teammates.
We both.
Why are my teammates...
You put 499.
I put 488.
Yeah.
I was like, okay, somebody put Spiderman.
I am not my sponsor.
I hope you have not my sponsor.
Ooh.
I hope you've ruined my new...
Oh, man.
Gorgeous new breakfast bowl.
I mean, that's...
This is...
Well, it's definitely...
It's definitely this.
It's one of your...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's definitely strawberry or coconut.
Yeah, but like the whole coconut is a seed apparently.
Oh, that pissed me off, that pissed me off.
We're both on the same team, Gumi, so it doesn't matter if either of us dies, we're both on the same team.
I know, but something about going against you makes my mouth hot.
Gumi, please, we have to work together!
Oh, you're dumb.
Sorry.
Hey, why does it seem like I have a lot of dice?
I feel like you died first though, Jag.
I won the first challenge, so you get to kill me now.
And that's all?
Which you won, so what now?
We've got the next game.
Time to roll.
Oh.
Here we go.
Oh!
No!
The dice don't lie.
Wait, do we win in a matter of rounds?
Wait, why did they kill you?
I thought they would kill me, not gonna lie.
What the heck's going on here?
I thought I was gonna die.
I was ready to kill you, I was doing it.
That was rough, that was rough.
Guys, I think I might die just from the fast trivia.
Is that the end of the game?
No, you have to do the fast trivia.
I'm basically against everybody.
Oh, no.
Dude!
This is hard.
Wait, I can't see the answers.
Wait, what?
Oh, no, because she only gets this.
Which one is this?
Oh, I know this.
I don't know this.
What do you mean?
I don't even know how to answer this.
Oh, you should have done it.
Fuck.
Oh, okay.
You're on your way to escaping.
But get this, all ghosts get to play, too.
Oh!
Yes.
Justin's for Jax.
What's going on here?
Another Jax open.
Here's everyone's next question.
And ghosts get a third choice to help them catch up to you.
Ginger root.
It's ginger.
What is it?
Oh, wait.
Shoot.
Everyone's playing now.
I'm trying to help my sister.
I don't know.
Is button not swash?
Ginger, ginger, ginger.
But I chose button not swash.
Oh, no.
I might die.
Oh, I know this.
I know this one, too.
Locked in.
Very good.
I know this.
I don't like cats like that.
What's going on?
Give me dog brain.
Russian boy, bro.
What the dog brain?
Oh, God.
Everybody's catching up.
Dog brain for the round table.
Oh.
Sir Malfoy.
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I read it.
I watch Monty Python.
I know this.
We're zooming.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
I don't know who in this team is catching up.
Oh, my God.
Do I still win my money if I die?
Human blood types.
What the fuck?
AC+.
Guys, I'm going to be honest.
I don't even know if this is correct.
Me neither.
I don't know.
Wait.
I forgot.
I wrote A.
Why did I put A?
Yes.
I forgot.
I forgot to uncheck it.
I wrote double A.
If it's not green, I'm actually just running through my wall as fast as I can because that doesn't make any sense.
Green letters.
No way.
Oh, no.
This game is so trolled.
What is that?
I'm too dumb for this.
Oh, I know this.
I know this.
I know this one too.
Easy.
Wait.
I don't know this.
What?
I don't know this either.
It's Rhode Island or Rhodes.
Rhodes.
Not Rhodes.
Go.
Okay.
I guessed the wrong one.
It's two.
Crazy.
Oh, I'm back.
I'm back, baby.
One of you win, please.
Oh, I don't know this.
Oh, my God.
This is so hard.
This is nerve-wracking.
Who's Alexander?
Dude, I don't know.
Hamilton.
Alexander Hamilton.
Oh, thank God.
Wait.
LM, go.
Oh, my God.
This will slow you down.
If you want to break through that barrier, you'll need a perfect answer to this question.
Oh, what?
Oh, shit.
What is this?
Oh, fuck.
I don't freaking know, bro.
Okay.
It's...
No.
Dude, why can't Boy Scouts learn suing?
That seems like an important skill.
Why don't you pick two answers?
No, no, no.
No.
Wait.
Ten's in.
Oh, my God.
I'm a goose.
Hold on.
Watch this.
This is crazy.
What is this?
Watch this.
This is so crazy.
I'm in here.
If you flex like this around, this is crazy.
Oh, my God.
I only picked one.
No.
There's all of us in here.
All of us.
I'm trying.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck is this scam?
I'm trying.
It's almost done.
It kind of looked like one.
No.
Go, go.
Go.
You got it.
Who was that?
I got it.
You got it.
Who was that?
I got to go down.
I got in.
What the frick is that?
Wait.
Who won?
No.
It wasn't me.
I'm funny.
No.
I'm so confused!
I don't even know what the right answer was!
I got the most points, it's alright.
It's all about the scores.
Where's my team?
I dropped out of community college.
I'm not made for this.
Jack, what are you doing out here?
Wait, VIP won again?
What are the odds?
Hey, I sent someone else to the VIP.
It's literally rigged.
I hate school.
We're on the same team, guys!
We're on the same team!
I can't believe I typed that whole thing out just to get it deleted.
That was my highlight of the day.
I can't believe you listened to me, Wig.
I don't know why I do everything.
The fact that you actually deleted it.
Why would you delete that?
Why didn't you delete it?
I was so stressed.
I was saying I couldn't type it because I didn't have the option to type.
I think you were just listening to me going, Yeah, I can't do it either.
You're an idiot.
Anything school-wise stresses me out.
Get me off this fucking thing.
Oh my god.
One last game, guys.
One last game.
Updates on the rankings?
Like, are we...
What's the rankings?
Maybe look at Twitch Rivals?
We have to look at the Twitch Rivals.
But we're not winning that hard either.
I feel like everyone's been doing pretty good.
So I feel like it's going to be pretty even.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
I feel like there's no clear winner yet.
Unless you guys have been dominating.
Well, I think our team has been winning a lot.
I think.
Maybe?
I don't know.
Doki Bird shows up to take my wins away.
Every game.
Every single game I play, she appears to win.
It's crazy, I tell you.
Maybe we should be on my team instead.
That's a good idea.
We had a title to protect, man.
We had a title to protect and we're losing it now.
We won the last trivia night, man.
Yeah, well, who got the least amount of points in Quiplash?
Me.
Oh, it was Wig.
Yeah, there you go.
That cost us, man.
That cost us.
That was a big penalty.
No, you got full Quiplash because of that.
Like, plus 6,000.
Yeah, I think it's all of us added together, right?
Isn't it like the collective points?
Well, I don't know.
I don't know.
I mean...
Well, we're against Ape's team last, so like, we're chilling, right?
Surely, right?
Surely.
I mean, it's Mafia, so...
Oh, we're against MiYong's team last.
Yeah, we got MiYong's team in the final bout.
Okay, that's going to be an easy win, right?
Damn, you're calling your team easy?
You say like that.
In the specific game that's coming up, Elem's a master of.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, Elem gets killed first every time in like Mafia games.
Where's Mafia A again, guys?
Oh, yeah.
We gotta switch, guys.
Well, actually...
Dude, Elem's an expert at this upcoming game, and he's just going to pipiga clap him.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
This is my game.
This is my one.
Sorry, guys.
We're taking over.
It's GG.
We're all doing our fair share.
Except for Tenzin.
No, no, no, no, no.
Tenzin might go.
Yeah.
I didn't die first.
Oh.
I didn't...
Well, I tied to die first, so...
I didn't put that all in.
You know what?
I'm absolved.
There was another Jack who's not doing so great.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Damn.
Wait, Peter's...
Peter's team's last, by the way.
What?
They spelled green wrong.
Dude, that's what I'm saying nicely.
It's because they spelled it wrong.
How is green not a lettuce?
It's literally green.
Yeah.
Is it a green?
That's true.
That's literally green.
I haven't involved in over a video game in like two years, but I think those just really stressed me out.
Made me mad.
I can't believe that.
Yeah.
The ending for Trivia Murder Party is always the hardest part.
We need a video game.
We need video game trivia.
That would get...
Ooh.
Yeah.
That would be fun.
Trivia for idiots.
That's like perfect.
Yeah.
We need to put some Minecraft trivia in there and see what happens.
Hey, what's up?
Hey, what up, man?
What's up, gamers?
Switch it up, guys.
Oh, wait.
I was in the lobby B.
Are we going down?
Yeah.
We're going down.
See you later, team.
Bye.
Bye, guys.
See you later.
Bye.
See you guys later.
What?
Hello.
You can get Nando sauce in the US?
Nando sauce in the US?
What the fuck?
Oh, hey, guys.
Yeah.
Apparently Walmart carries Nando sauce.
Who won in your lobby?
I did.
Oh.
Oh, you guys might be third, then.
No.
Let me just like...
The last question was so fucking troll.
It was like, what's the key on the bottom of a QWERTY keyboard?
So everyone just looked at their keyboards.
You know what's the best part?
Someone fucking got it wrong.
Who?
Who got it wrong?
Who was it?
Call them out.
I won't say, but they're very short.
I don't know.
I'm not in this call.
Talking.
You got it wrong.
I'm not going to say who.
Not in this call, that's it.
But like, you might not be able to see them over like a standard kitchen counter top.
You know what I mean?
Damn.
I think the type that I require is uppies in order to engage in conversation.
Yvonne?
Like they have a collapsible tool that...
Yep.
How'd you know?
How the fuck did you know?
That's crazy.
Who in the chat?
I'm in chat.
Yes, man.
All but Yvonne law!
No, no man, like I feel like I didn't really give enough hints.
Yeah, not at all.
Oh really!
You painted a good picture there, I think?
It could have been Ape honestly.
Whoa!
Oh, I thought he spit...
Let me just tell Ape something real quick.
Okay.
Whoa!
Wait, wait.
Banned from every collab.
All right.
Right...
So, how do you play gamble?
I think I pushed the button.
Dude, he ratted me out.
That's crazy.
He ratted me out.
My own teammate.
I'm going to grief him this game.
Jaqen, you talking shit?
Of course not.
You little bitch.
You're my goat.
Oh, I thought I was your goat.
Oh, no.
He's my silver goat.
Jaqen's kind of like a goat slut.
He just throws that word around.
What the hell?
I got multiple goats.
Jaqen, listen.
You're dead to me.
You don't mean that, do you?
Try not getting 8th for once.
Doki, you know what's crazy?
All three games Jaqen's played, he's gotten the lowest points.
Damn!
Wait, whose team is he in?
Wait, Peter.
You're in my lobby.
Damn!
Is this why Peter's last place?
Jaqen, you've been last place first game and second game.
This trivia murder party?
This is your time to shine.
Literally gets eliminated first.
Shit!
Yeah, Peter's team is last place.
How did you guys see that?
Because they did an overall standings.
I'm at the bottom right now?
Well, they didn't count this game yet.
They didn't count the third game yet.
But after two games, Peter's team was last.
Jaqen, this is a team effort.
But let's just say you're bringing down the team.
I love family game night, guys.
No, no, no.
Nah, I can't.
Say it, say it.
You grieved the first game.
Because you got too greedy.
But didn't Peter win?
Yeah.
But you got too greedy so everything was on fire.
Peter had the most points.
Yeah, I had the most points on my team.
Is that not the point of the game?
But Jaqen, my team also gained a lot of points and we're in the same family.
Yeah.
I actually got less points than Gumi.
Gumi was greedier than I was and yet their team still won.
So Jaqen, what's your...
Wait, didn't Jaqen stop Peter when Peter got too greedy?
Didn't you actually try to stop him?
Yeah, Jaqen, you could have actually allowed me to score more points for my team and yet you stopped me.
I was trying but you got too greedy.
But isn't being greedy the whole point in letting your family win?
Yeah, that's the point.
No, if you get too greedy...
It's a shared money.
We should have survived the night but we didn't.
That's true.
I don't think they expected us to survive the night to be fair.
Yeah, we all died because people got greedy.
But even, like, no one won.
Wait, Jaqen, I don't think you actually understand the rules of the first game if you think that you're not supposed to be greedy.
Like, you're stopping me from winning us the game.
No, but you got too greedy.
No, listen, Goomy was greedier than I was.
Like, she literally studied the game.
I was not.
Wait, wait, wait.
Goomy, Goomy, Goomy.
We were both setting the same amount of fires but your team let her through because you understood how to play the game.
No, I flooded the basement once.
No, you also set two fires.
I remember when I shit.
At least, Peter, Peter.
You guys are third now.
Ellum's last.
Your win for the third game got you the third place.
Okay, I'm gonna cook in this one.
Goomy, Goomy, Goomy.
If you lose this game, you're still first, right?
Like, it doesn't affect the standings for you.
But for me, right?
I could win over Ellum, so just come on.
We'll do anything, Goomy.
Just let us know first.
Listen, I don't even know what the next game is.
I don't know either.
We're in the spaceship.
It's like Aliens and Hunters or some shit.
Oh, Goomy, you're so good at that.
Oh, the code is up.
Yeah.
Wait, it's up?
It's fine.
We've got this team.
Yeah, I believe in us.
Maybe losing in points, but you know, we're doing great in team spirit.
Your teammate is an alien to not really go for them?
Am I right about that?
Yes, but I don't know if you're gonna know who your teammate is.
I think you don't know who it is.
If you suspect them, it's better to just let them.
Yeah, if you suspect it's them, just let them chill a bit.
Alright, guys.
I guess we'll see each other's avatars too, right?
So, like, if we can memorize each other's avatars, then that would...
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna take a screenshot.
In case I don't see the avatars.
Okay, Loki, everyone kinda looks like their avatars.
Especially Doki.
Haha.
Yeah, I'm actually 80 years old, guys.
Wait, I like this.
I like the hair.
Thank you.
It's my birthday.
That's why I'm wearing a birthday hat.
Happy birthday!
Yeah!
It's my birthday!
Can you guys sing happy birthday to me?
Yeah!
No, no, no.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Happy birthday to you.
Wow, thank you guys.
You guys made my birthday very special.
Oh.
It's over, man.
Are we ready to go?
Yeah, they were ready, right?
Let's go.
Oh, okay.
Did they ask for... yeah.
Alright, how to play a game.
Uh... yeah.
Yeah.
Sorry to interrupt your cryo sleep, but I thought it worth mentioning that I, your digital officer during emergencies, or Doki, have detected an alien biorhythm on the ship.
That's embarrassing.
And just as I suspected, the aliens uploaded the virus, which is slowly donating to my program.
I'm here to guide you through if you'd like.
Yeah.
Yes.
I would love a tutorial.
Yeah, we don't know what's going on.
We'll go for the tutorial.
Security protocol.
Fifth.
Dementia.
Online.
Which is a series of tests designed to evaluate your humanity and reveal any aliens hiding amongst you.
Among us.
Hehe.
Among you.
Oh, cute.
Secretly aliens.
Please look at your device and confirm your identity.
You are human.
I'm human.
Or an alien.
Human in all caps, period.
Unfortunately, aliens will know who their compatriots are, so you'll be at a bit of a disadvantage, humans.
Tenzin, do you know if you're human or an alien?
Sorry, sorry.
Guys, she lost her ID.
She doesn't remember.
Oh, I don't know how to lie.
No, no, no, no.
Oh.
So there's three aliens.
Hello, Peter.
Cool.
I don't know what that means.
When do we click the button?
Let's do drawing quarters because Lily likes drawing.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Lily's been waiting to draw all day.
No, I haven't.
I'm not going to have Lily draw, though, unfortunately.
Wait, please.
Please give me this.
Wait, how do I join?
Oh, he picks the people.
Welcome to the drawing quarters.
Let's find out who the aliens are right now.
Draw the best you can because the alien virus will give our intruders a similar yet different prompt.
Oh.
Cast suspicion on any It's so funny.
Those drawings are so good.
As time goes on, I'll do my best to send the aliens harder prompts.
You're welcome.
Okay.
Oh, wow, this game lasts 18 in real life minutes?
No, I think it's like the whole game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, that's what I meant.
I didn't think it would last 18 whole minutes.
Are you going to rush to somewhere to be?
No, no, no.
What does that mean?
I don't know, but I'm scared to touch it.
I can hurry you guys if you want.
You know, I'm going to hurry because Lily's going to have too much detail.
Oh, it's the timer.
Oh, guys, you guys only have like 10 seconds.
Oh, it moves that.
Oh.
Okay.
All right.
Spend more time, I think, right?
Oh, no, I was thinking because...
Oh.
.
Clearly, she's...
She is really good at Apex, to be fair.
The third one's cooking?
Yeah, right?
.
Our favorite thing to do.
Guys, no, I'm human.
I swear to God, I'm human.
I swear to God.
Guys, I swear to God.
I just did...
I don't have a talent, so I was like, what do I do, you know?
.
I'm laughing.
Okay.
.
Let's go to...
the Onion Hold.
.
I would like to test...
you, you, and you.
.
Sorry, I'm high.
Okay, I mean, they all seem, like, believable, so I don't know.
.
I feel like this one was, like, kind of, whatever.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Oh, that's why I'm scared.
You never know, you know?
.
Oh.
This thing is fun.
I'ma choose you.
Yay!
Jack hasn't yet.
And everybody else has already.
I would choose you as well.
Oh, me?
Me?
I'm human!
Yeah, yeah!
.
Really, your birthday?
I guess it's wrong.
Why did you say that out loud?
Hurry up.
Oh, wait.
No, I did it wrong.
Guys,
please, don't sabotage me, please.
Interesting.
You did it wrong, huh?
Intriguing.
Oh, no.
What do I want?
Oh, I know what I want.
I'm not an artist, so...
Ah, it's beeping and scaring me!
Draw a birthday present.
Oh, that's gonna be fun.
Wait, okay.
I don't know.
Would you clarify?
Like, what's the...
No, because I thought it meant a birthday present that we're giving people, and I like money, so people would give me money for birthday presents.
Is that how you look?
Yeah, that's how I went in.
I didn't realize it meant you draw an exact birthday present.
Guys, please, I'm here.
We're human.
We're losers.
You guys vote for me, please.
Why are you angry, though?
Why are you angry?
I swear.
I'm just doing this really badly.
You just look like a character.
I'm literally throwing for content, guys.
Yeah.
I can't read, please.
Sweetie God, I'm human.
What are we thinking?
Are we confident?
Like, do we have an idea?
I don't know.
I'm dropping.
I'm popping.
Guys, I swear to God, I'm throwing for content.
Wait, what is happening?
We need three aliens.
Alright, hold on.
Are we doing all at once?
Hold on.
Why?
We don't have enough info.
Wait, I don't get it.
Do we not get the same answer on the prompt?
If you're human and you vote me up...
You know what?
No.
I hope Peter votes me up.
Wait, I'm so dead right now.
I hope Peter votes me up just because, like, humans will lose if he gets the wrong one.
These are just my suspicions.
But if you don't want to vote up...
We actually lose if we vote, though.
You can vote against.
Vote failed, guys.
It's okay.
I will say that I would put Doki there, too.
I know we were just together, but...
No!
We voted me out!
Peter would lose!
I'm gonna be honest, guys.
That's my bad.
I didn't know we were voting three up.
I'm hella sus of Doki.
Wait, we should drunk that damn up already.
This is really bad at this game.
I don't do well on depression, guys.
Don't get up there.
Why me?
I'm just a human.
I just want to see you draw, man.
No, oh, no, no.
Sorry if you already drew it.
I was not paying attention to who was drawing.
Hurry up.
Actually, you're welcome, Lily.
Oh.
You guys got five seconds?
Okay, you good?
Why are you laughing?
Dude, she's definitely fucking with someone.
Yes, she is.
We definitely know which one is the alien.
I know what you did.
I got nervous.
I submitted early, even though I didn't need to.
Same.
Pause.
Oh, it stopped.
You're digitizing.
Because I swear I'm human, guys.
I'm just very suspicious.
I'm bad at this game.
Wait, what?
My thing didn't go through.
Wait, what did you draw?
Peter, what did you draw?
A yapper.
What do you mean?
With no mouths?
It just looks like they're about to hug.
Wait.
It's a baby by accident.
It's not a baby at all.
Mine didn't go through.
Mine says mansplaining on it.
Mansplaining?
That's kind of sus.
I think Gumi is good.
I mean, they're all good.
Clearly, his worst date is no date.
Wait,
so we don't have to vote, right?
You don't have to.
What?
Just because my drawing is bad?
Leave me alone.
Wait, how many rounds do we get for this?
We got nine minutes to figure out.
Nine?
There's a timer.
Holy shit, this is a long game.
Golly.
You'll be able to analyze any player and find out if they're an alien.
Oh.
Guys, I swear to god, just scan me.
I swear to god.
We shouldn't scan Dookie.
We know for sure it's her.
So who should I do?
Someone you trust and someone you don't trust.
Guys, please.
You should probably do people on the opposite team that you think is a bad guy.
That would get us the most points.
You're right, don't scan me.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's fine.
Okay.
I think that's reasonable.
I don't know, I just picked someone.
The bioscanner.
Unfortunately, the virus has got this place.
Oh.
The consequence will see a set of alien glyphs on their device.
The captain will only see three glyphs and must describe them out loud.
Lily, you're screwed.
If the glyphs match, the test will pass.
Wait, all of us has to have it?
No, no, no.
Lily will listen to me intending what the symbols look like.
The aliens may fail by tapping the wrong glyph on purpose.
Oh.
Okay, listen.
The middle one looks like a person tripping.
And his right arm is like out in the air.
And his right foot is also in the air.
I got it.
The left one looks like...
Ah, shoot.
It's like mirrored.
There's a...
Oh, shit.
Oh, poop.
With the circle at the bottom?
Yeah, the circle at the top.
It's like a fat T, but horizontal.
And then there's another one to the opposite side of it.
But the line is bigger that's like coming out of it.
It looks like a person like kicking almost.
I see it.
And it's mirrored?
Yes, it's mirrored.
And there's one circle at the top.
Kind of diagonally.
It makes a diagonal line.
Yes, it's also diagonal.
Okay, got that one.
Okay, and the third one looks like a...
It looks like a ghost with a little stick pointing out at the top.
And there's two circles in it.
One in its head and one in its body.
Yeah, it looks like Vex from League.
Kind of.
It's a bell shape.
And the bottom is open.
Tenzin, are you okay?
You haven't said anything.
Okay.
I am truly trying hard to understand.
Tenzin, you haven't said anything.
I'm worried.
Sorry.
I'm telling you.
I'm not lying.
I'm focusing really hard.
The first one, it looks like a guy.
He's kicking to the right.
And he has something on his back that looks like his body.
But it's mirrored.
Oh, so he's mirrored.
Yeah.
And the second one, the guy...
He tripped and fell.
His right arm is to the sky.
The right leg is to the sky.
So it's the same as the other one?
No.
What?
What part of that?
He's also tripping.
He's tripping.
Yeah, so there's two people tripping.
The second one...
Wait, is it an alien?
Does it have an antenna?
Yes, a tiny little antenna.
The third one has an antenna.
Okay, so two of them are both not tripping.
Oh, man.
Wait, where's the timer?
At the bottom, at the bottom!
Three, two, one.
Oh, dude.
Uh-oh.
You tried your best, man.
You tried your best.
Let me see.
I thought you said two tripping.
That was close, Tenzin.
And I clicked the wrong one?
It's okay, Tenzin.
You tried your best.
Sorry, I thought you guys said two tripping.
So I took off the other one, which was the last one.
Wait, what does this mean?
So this means Jack got all of them right.
So Jack is pretty human to me.
But Tenzin, I don't know.
Wait, I'm sorry.
I thought you said he's tripping twice.
This one's kind of hard.
I kind of believe Tenzin.
Yeah, this one's hard.
Yeah, that was a hard one.
Wait, I would have had the wrong one.
I mean, the one I was asking about.
That's the only one I get wrong.
What's with all the alarms?
We have five minutes left to figure out the aliens.
Oh, we're so scared.
I feel like aliens is easier to be.
Wait, what's Riding Pod?
I don't know.
What is that?
Who has been tested the least?
I'm so bad at Riding Pod.
Wait, you know I'm human.
Put me against...
Oh, that's true.
I'm also a human, Doki.
I'm sorry, Jack.
Welcome to the Riding Pod.
I get hacked here?
By the last alien?
The alien virus will allow the intruders to get something similar but not quite right.
When the correct prompt is revealed, it will be up to you to determine if any seem odd.
Oh.
As time winds down, I'll do my best to send the aliens some real stinkers.
It's the least I can do.
What does that mean?
Does that mean I'm hacked?
No, I think all of us are.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I think the time is just going down.
Yeah, because the virus.
The longer the aliens are here, the more virus there'll be.
How do you know so much about that, Doki?
That's kind of crazy.
Well, that's what Christine literally just said.
I thought the aliens are viruses.
It's like a look here.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's me.
Not me.
Okay, well.
That's so funny.
Just for background of my one, I'm allergic to dairy.
What did your prompt say?
So you would say, ew, if you saw Why were you very specific?
Why couldn't you say milk?
Milk?
I don't want to be fancy.
I don't want to be basic.
I feel like you should put the people you're suspicious onto the drawing.
Please don't put me again.
I'm actually not an alien.
Please don't put me back in there.
Get your drawing fingers ready.
Oh, we have three minutes.
Alright, everybody press hurry.
Everybody press hurry.
Press hurry!
So, what prompt did you guys get?
Don't worry about it.
I'm submitting...
I feel rushed.
I'm submitting.
Tenzin, what's your prompt?
I'm drawing.
We need to have a talk.
What?
Peter, what did you draw?
Peter, what is that?
When you draw a skeleton, do you see the ribs?
Oh, I know.
Tenzin.
Okay.
Ariana Grande from Fortnite.
Tenzin, what did you draw?
Okay.
Sorry to all the Arienators.
I wasn't hacked.
I got draw something spooky, but I just tried drawing a skeleton, but it was really bad.
Okay.
You had lots of... Okay.
I feel like I know who the three are.
I feel like we all know, right?
Yeah.
Is Gumi gonna do it though?
You only get one minute, so act quickly.
Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see...
Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see... Gumi, I see...
I feel like this is not quite right, is it?
That was my suspicion.
We only have one alien and we have two, so our multiplier is bigger than them.
One minute.
You only have one minute and 30 seconds.
I want to try the bioscanner.
I got you, Goomy.
Who do you want to go against?
I don't know anyone.
Please, please, put me in and you'll know I'm not an alien.
Please, I swear to God.
Shut up!
We're all on the same team, Goomy!
Jack, choose someone.
Oh, really?
Do I have to choose someone?
Choose Peter.
I think he's very suspicious.
Fuck it.
Choose me.
I don't care.
Choose someone.
Time.
Who should I pick?
The more you decide, we're running out of time.
You have to pick.
We have very low on time.
Wait, I think Jack is purposely stalling.
Jack?
Jack is stalling?
Wait, push the button.
Push the button if he's stalling.
I'm hacked.
I don't have button.
I'm holding.
I'm pushing.
I did it.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Okay, Lily, put Doki, Jack.
So it has to be Jack?
Doki, Jack, and I don't know who the last one is.
Maybe Tenzin.
Tenzin?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, I think it is.
I think it is.
Wait, really?
Oh my God.
Guys, it's not me.
I guess there's one way to find out.
It's not me, guys.
If you guys pick me, you're very bad at deduction, guys.
No, it's not me.
Pick Doki.
Who?
I didn't want this end of it, no?
No, oh, no.
Guys, all I'm saying is that I was just really bad.
I was just very suspicious and bad at this game.
This is the end of the game, guys.
Wait, but then if Jack and Tenzin are the aliens...
Wait, you guys gotta vote.
The aliens win, but then Jack and Tenzin are on our team, and we'll get more points.
I don't know.
I think you should get more points.
You have to get them all right.
I think the team thing is making it really hard.
Yeah.
You have a different incentive.
All right.
I don't think it was Tenzin.
See you later, alien scum.
Oh, my God.
What?
Doki, it's not you?
It was never you.
I told you.
I literally told you guys.
I knew it was Peter.
See you later.
One was adjacent.
I knew it was him, too, but...
Good job, everyone.
My prompt initial, by the way, was what would you describe as mousey?
Glimpse, dony.
We did everything.
Not only did Evan and I win, we got the other alien out that wasn't on our team.
I fumbled out, huh?
That's not good.
Wait, but did we get points because we have?
We got an alien.
Doki, why did you get them all wrong?
You actually knew it for content.
I knew it.
Doki's just a content machine, bro.
I was so clear.
I was human!
You were the intimator.
I was so clear.
I did not at all.
You really weren't.
I did not.
You really weren't clear on it.
I was like put me in and you can tell I'm human.
I was like push the button because he's stalling.
Why are you so sus bro?
Jesus Christ.
It's just me.
Like I knew the answers and I'm like Doki is...
Should have just told me that Tenzin.
I'm kind of surprised you guys didn't vote for me by the way.
I'm just naturally suspicious.
I just wanted to get every alien right.
I just naturally suspicious.
I was not present in this game I'm gonna be real.
Yeah she's not an Among Us player.
Bro and Peter drew that fucking thing on the picture.
And he's like this is a skeleton.
I was like there's no way.
Okay to be honest my prompt was actually correct.
I didn't know I was hacked.
I didn't know I was hacked to have a correct prompt.
I tried to draw something vague.
Oh that's good.
What is that?
That was the final game right?
Hosea.
That was good.
Wait so like how are the points done?
Does that mean like...
Our team also got points because Tenzin was in the aliens team.
Like that I don't understand.
I'm gonna be honest.
I'm gonna just let God decide because I have no fucking idea.
Whoever wins good job.
GG's everyone.
GG's.
GG's yeah it was fun.
That's the main thing.
You know how Dakit almost got me voted out when he was throwing suspicion my way?
Oh my god yeah I was like wait a second.
Now Dakit?
Are you serious?
I'm gonna curse you.
Yeah you're worse than no teammate.
I mean what?
Wait.
Dakit almost got you called out.
But you don't mean that.
Wait take it back.
No I don't mean that.
It's not like you almost got me voted out.
No.
Somebody says I think they lose points because Lily picked the ejection.
Wait is that how it goes?
Oh.
Is that how it works?
No.
Surely not right?
Or somebody says push the button.
I don't know man.
Oh my gosh.
Why do our teams push the button as an individual?
Wait I didn't know that was an individual.
Yeah I thought two of my teammates were aliens so I wanted to throw it to them.
Yeah.
You were throwing as a human so I was confused.
Adelki was throwing it herself?
I told you guys I was really bad at this game.
I was very clear.
We were doing bad before they could even hack.
I could've sworn you out.
Oh this is so easy.
There's no way we fucking lose this.
She says naturally sauce bro.
Yeah.
People just think I'm suspicious even though I try to save the game I say push the button because he's stalling.
What were those bad drawings about then?
I'm illiterate.
I thought it was a straw.
I can't read.
Because they couldn't even hack yet and you're still doing the prize roll.
I can't read because it says straw birthday present.
I was like oh what I won as a birthday gift so then I drew myself holding money because that's what I envisioned.
Who trolled on us?
I think you're angry.
I appreciate the creativity.
I was just trying to be creative.
I didn't really.
You get points for that.
You did well creativity-wise.
I like how you had to specify creativity.
Well good job aliens you really turned that one.
Honestly that was good.
Yeah.
Dude, when Anavan had the fucking chocolate sundae I was like oh it's fucking over.
My prompt was a cool joke.
Yeah, it was for sure one, and I had some on Peter, but you're a good liar.
Yeah, also like, we got, no, we made Peter draw twice, and the first one was when he was like, two people were just standing there.
It looked like they were fighting.
I felt like Doki was doing most of the lying for me.
Like, she just brought all the attention on herself.
Yeah.
Let's get our alien prize money, honestly, at this point.
I was like, damn, dude, Doki's really making my job easy.
Hell yeah, let's go.
I should, I wish I was the alien.
For free?
For concert?
Are we done?
Is that it?
I think so.
The other game is still going.
Oh, who are the aliens over there, I wonder?
It looks like they're doing the last voting too.
Oh god.
Yeah, they have eight seconds left, but it's frozen.
Oh my god.
Who is it?
Elem Sykkuno.
Okay, to be honest, Elem could go either way.
I saw Yvonne go earlier in, but they took her out.
I would not want to do it.
No, it's Yvonne.
Oh, Yvonne.
Elem Sykkuno.
Elem and Doki are the same level.
I hope Elem's also human.
Doki's saying goodbye to this place.
Oh my god.
Wait, are they going to be able to press the button?
Wait, someone has to push a button right now.
What are they doing?
You need to push the button.
Oh, so aliens won.
Oh my god, the aliens won.
Oh, if they voted correctly, they would have won.
Oh my god.
Nice wig.
It was the whole team.
Oh.
Nice alien win for them.
That's your whole team, right?
Yeah.
They're the big dudes.
Oh wow.
That was great.
But like, Elem's against Peter for third and fourth place.
Because Peter was third place and Elem was fourth place.
So potentially, Elem could be third.
And then Peter could be last.
Oh my god.
We've got this.
Third place locked in.
We both won that.
Listen, we and you won game three and four.
So if we lose, it's just not on us.
It's literally just not on us.
Game two, two.
I'm not going to say names.
I'm not naming names.
I feel like I was doing good in spirit.
In spirit.
Maybe in like the Holy Spirit.
Like you went to church or something.
Because definitely not in the spirit of this game.
Thank you, man.
Damn.
That's fucked.
You tried your best.
Your best just wasn't good.
God, really.
Honestly.
Dude, I just...
You made us look better.
That's true.
Yeah.
I think about my boys, you know.
Team player.
You're the support of the team.
Exactly.
The moral support.
Can we move up there and talk to them?
I think we can.
Yeah.
Let's move up.
Mingle?
At the end.
At the end, guys.
We did it.
We won.
How do we find out who like wins the whole thing?
It's on Twitch Rivals.
I mean, we could just add them and be like, tell us instead of...
Ellum, they're saying they want an interview with our team.
Ellum, they want an interview.
Does that mean we won the whole thing?
Ellum, go.
If no, it's my entire team.
Go, Ellum.
Go.
I think we won.
No.
Ellum, go.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Do your interview, man.
You deserve this.
Team Ellum, baby.
Captain.
Ellum.
Let's go.
Captain.
Number one alien.
Hey.
Get in there, man.
Ellum was not slick with it.
Number one alien.
It was definitely nice.
I was slick with it.
I was very slick with it.
Thank you very much.
I'm surprised that you guys didn't vote out Ellum, like, first night.
Like, what's happening?
We were trying to.
Yeah.
Wait, but who keeps...
The instructions were...
The instructions were kind of unclear.
Wait, what?
We didn't know if you could...
We clearly won the game.
Am I right, boys?
We didn't know if you could vote people out individually.
Yeah.
Could you vote...
Oh, yeah.
We didn't know that either.
Yeah.
You don't have to vote out three at once.
Oh, really?
You could do it individually?
Oh, we would have done that ages ago.
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't know that either.
I thought I had to vote...
Yeah.
For the three people.
We should call for a rematch.
Let's just pull onto each other.
No, no, no.
You guys would have won that then.
Someone fucking said, you have to pick all three.
Someone said those goddamn words.
Who said that?
I said that, but I...
I feel like that's correct, but I guess...
Guys, I'm switching goals.
Did we win?
Yeah, I don't know.
Wait, I don't know.
Does that mean we won?
They're calculating it now.
Cool.
I'm punching the numbers.
In the numbers.
I've got a good feeling.
Oh.
Wait, so who do they want to speak to?
You.
Is it everybody?
They want all of us in there.
Oh, they want everyone?
Yeah.
We all won.
Surely they can't interview us if we lose the game.
That would be...
That would be brutal.
That would be funny.
We all won.
Wait, people in my chat said you have to vote all three.
My chat said you have to vote for all three.
Who's lying?
Who lied?
Yeah, you have to vote for all three.
Okay.
The game's over.
Why are you lying?
Yeah.
Why did you lie?
Who's the alien?
It's already over.
Wait.
Who of us even just said that?
It's great.
Wait.
Did Ellen's team actually win overall?
I guess because they were all aliens, right?
So they got all the money.
Yeah.
So we probably got like a jillion points.
Because they all...
That's so RNG.
Why aren't I where?
Why aren't you with your team?
Is it just them?
What do you mean?
Where's my team?
Well, everyone else is down there.
Yeah.
No one told me.
I thought they dragged me.
Go down there.
Go.
Did they forgot about you?
Like, what happened?
Did you hear him?
I thought they were gonna drag me.
Wait.
How?
Oh.
Bless him.
Bless his heart.
Bless his soul.
I can't believe from one game, they went from fourth to first.
That's crazy.
What the fuck?
Deccan, I just need you to not be last for one of the games, man.
Not last for one of the games.
You know what?
He probably did his best, eh?
Good work, everyone.
Wait.
How did Deccan do?
Deccan even said that he didn't try his best.
Wait.
Deccan, I can't keep defending you, man.
How did Deccan do in the last game?
No.
Listen.
I didn't even try.
No.
I said I was gonna throw.
Because you were so mean to me.
What?
Yeah.
Oh.
So you inted on purpose.
That's bannable, actually.
Wait.
No.
Of course I didn't do that.
Oh.
Which one was it, Deccan?
Uh.
I just...
before really poorly, unfortunately.
Oh.
At least you're honest.
You know...
It happens.
Yeah.
I relate.
Oh?
We all had fun.
That's the main thing.
Not all of us.
I didn't know how it was this competitive.
I'm not going to lie.
I was just...
Am I drawing nice, friendly, casual game of...?
And then I got Petr and he just yelled at me.
And I was like...
My only goal is not last, man.
That's ridiculous!
I can't believe though from one game because of RNG.
Not really.
I'm thinking that doesn't care about scoreboard and stuff.
Valorant, Valorant, Valorant.
Your kid would be in good place.
Ah, that sounded kinda sarcastic.
Huh?
No.
That sounds sarcastic?
Oh, you meant it?
I just had Peter yell at me the whole day so I couldn't tell.
Oh, oh god.
Peter, you traumatized the man.
Dude, okay, grow a sack then.
Holy shit.
Yeah, you're right, you're right, you're right.
Oh my god.
I'll grow a sack.
No, no, he's right.
I thought you were going to say firm handshake.
Firm handshake.
No, he's right.
He's right.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm just going to grow some sacks.
GG's.
GG's, Lily.
Bye bye.
Why does it say Team Elements fourth place?
Wait, what?
Oh, it's linked out.
It's linked.
Are they still calculating it?
No, they're still calculating it.
Yeah, they're probably still calculating it.
Yeah, but I'm pretty sure they asked them in their team chat that they won.
Yeah.
Because, like, three aliens with...
Wait, we're above?
No, no, no.
That's not updated yet, Deccan.
Oh.
Yeah, because, like, they all went to, like, the...
They just wrote that.
We were 50 points ahead of the last place.
And then Team Elements just got, like, the most insane aliens.
Yeah, because all three of them were aliens.
So they...
And, like, it's, like, half...
It's, like, more than half the prize money.
What part of Young's team, then?
Yeah, I guess it would be dependent on, like, the other team.
I don't know their team's performance, but I have a feeling that we're just going to have to...
I thought the last game...
I thought the last game was only individual prizing, though.
Yeah, but they added into the total score.
Oh, did they?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
They're getting, like, kind of...
How sure are you?
I feel like you just made that up.
Well, they took the whole...
They added a whole team for the interview.
Teehee didn't actually throw up?
Teehee?
Oh, man.
I assume so, because the whole team's in the interview stage, and they usually interview the winners, right?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's team prizing.
Yeah.
Yeah, winners.
Yeah, they just updated it.
LM's team just won.
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Final results, I think.
That's the most disgusting thing I've ever seen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The RNG!
The fucking RNG!
Wait, the RNG?
LM won, I think.
Wait.
Oh, that...
Like, Among Us probably took those.
We were all the aliens, right?
Yeah.
Well, we...
Like, our game was...
You were first.
Our game was weird, because, like, one of our team members was an alien.
I'm sorry.
I thought you were an imposter doki.
Yeah.
My bad.
No, even if we won, I think other teams would have won overall, just because, like, they had all three.
We had more imposters, yeah.
And then...
Yeah.
And we only had one imposter.
We didn't have a chance.
It was just RNG.
It was RNG.
Yeah.
This is not a real...
It's Jackbox, guys.
Yeah.
Do you guys want to be champions of Jackbox?
Yes.
I already am.
I'll see you in Call of Duty, man.
Wait.
So, these are the final results, right?
Yeah.
I think so.
Do me, and then mine, and then Peter, and then Elm.
Oh!
We got third place!
We're in third place!
Let's go.
Wait.
Who's last?
Hey.
Wait.
So, victory for us.
So, individual?
It was, like, six people?
Wait.
So, nothing changed then?
What the fuck are they interviewing Elm?
Maybe because all three of them won at the end there.
Maybe.
Yeah.
What if we all just join the interview call and just start talking shit about Elm?
Why are you interviewing the last place team?
I don't know.
That's all you, Tiger.
That's all you.
I take everything back.
Good job, Ben.
You did your best.
Good job.
Not last, baby.
Let's go.
Not last.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
What does it show the listing?
You're my goat.
You're my goat, Dagger.
Wait.
Really?
Yeah, man.
You're my goat.
Thank you so much, Mr. PP.
are my bigger goats, but, like, you're part of the goat pack.
Okay.
No.
I'll take that.
I'm higher up on the mountain.
technically, because, like, she did throw for us.
Yeah.
It's in the Twitch Rivals link they sent us.
And then...
Family game night presented by Mythwalker.
Like, this, like, at the top.
There's two things you can press on.
Basically, individual scoring is just going to be the six people that won as aliens in the games.
You're welcome, Tiger.
Wait.
After the link and then what?
Yeah, but...
I'm just sad.
It's at the top.
It's at the very top.
It says Family Game Night.
Individual prize and then...
Six people.
Individually, there's a six-way tie.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, that's for push the button, though.
Not for...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
What the fuck?
Then, like...
Peter and Tenzin should be in that interview as well!
You guys won with them!
They weren't you guys in the interview.
It is what it is.
Maybe they just wanted to interview the losers.
That's true!
They wanted to make them feel better!
For being last!
Like, they had such a great performance, and it didn't matter at all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In the end...
I honestly am genuinely so confused.
I don't know.
Are these standings correct?
Because I feel like the points didn't change.
Yeah, I'm kind of wondering.
I remember being 50 points ahead of Team LM before.
And it still says we're 50 points ahead of LM.
I'm pretty sure.
Well, I don't think the last game counted towards the total points.
Yeah, I think it's an individual.
Because the last game was for individual prizing.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
That makes sense, yeah.
Okay, wait.
I'm not gonna pretend like I get that.
What?
So, in the end, Peter, you're not last.
It's LM's team.
Because the last round did not count as a team result.
So, in the end, Sykkuno should...
Wait, no.
Sykkuno was an alien, so...
How would they count the last game as, like...
As, like, a team result.
Yeah, because, like...
Because it's random who gets alien and who gets human, right?
Yeah, it's clearly RNG.
So, it's only for whoever wins as, like, aliens.
Yeah.
Wait, how did Tenzin...
Or wins as humans.
Wait, why doesn't Tenzin win?
Yeah, didn't Tenzin get voted out?
Yeah, but she's part of the alien team.
So, because you guys won, she takes the win.
Because not all of you guys got voted out.
Yeah.
Tenzin was the alien.
I'm joking.
Take it out, Sykkuno.
Peter, are you serious?
I just came back because I just heard what you said.
I'm being real.
I only remember the end of it.
I thought you were actually...
I thought you were, like, building it up for me.
And then you, kind of, bailed me out.
I was like, oh, that was really smart, Peter.
You, fuck!
I didn't even realize.
They didn't even realize you were the alien.
Listen, listen.
Maybe I remembered at the time.
But right now, nothing's sticking.
Hey.
That's my bad, bro.
Welcome back, guys.
Yeah.
Apparently, we won the whole thing.
Thanks to that one last round.
Wait, really?
We were in the literal last place.
We had triple aliens.
Yeah, we were in the last place, but the triple aliens were not updated.
Yeah, because the website says you're last.
The website's wrong, then.
Yeah, it says you guys are still last.
I think because they didn't update for that one.
They didn't update it, yeah.
I feel like you guys are going to have to do some live.
I can't take it anymore.
Everyone in our lobby.
Did you know that Sykkuno didn't know that he was an alien the whole time?
I missed the screen that told me, like, who the other aliens were and stuff.
So I was just playing the game.
Wait, what are you missing?
That's a confirm.
He didn't see it.
I just didn't straight up see it.
I think he was supposed to tell me who the other aliens were at some point.
It did, yeah.
Oh, the points.
I never saw that.
It never...
The points is literally just, like, one to one dollar value.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay, so in the end...
So because LM's team had three aliens that won, it boosted their points up by, like, 900.
What the f**k?
Dang.
We needed that.
That's crazy.
Damn.
I mean, wait.
How is it, like, the last game basically is what matters?
Yeah, your team got 840 points for the last game.
Because I'm assuming you guys had two aliens, right?
Yes, yes.
Two aliens.
Yeah.
Are these standings correct?
I'm so confused.
No, no, no, no.
They just showed it on Rivals.
Oh, yeah.
Are we last?
That's the main thing we're worried about.
Are we at least the highest?
No, no, no.
No, I think we were last.
Yeah, Team A was last.
Wait, who's third?
Are we third then?
Oh, we're third?
Oh, my God.
Oh, we're not last.
I think I...
I'm going to be honest, guys.
Wait, no, we're second!
I sacked with my team because we didn't want LM to get last again and feel bad.
I was like, what do you mean?
I was better.
Yeah, honestly, this is the kind of stuff I do.
This is the kind of s**t I do for the homies, you know?
Wait, really?
Oh, yeah.
That's my guy.
This is the kind of guy that I am.
Wait, I have the standings.
I posted in chat.
This is the final standings.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
Look at how much money they got.
LM's team got...
That's a lot of money.
Okay, I'm going to be honest.
We all kind of made around the same amount of money.
$4,000.
The same.
Yeah.
I'm going to be narrow on that.
Honestly, it kind of worked out.
Honestly, that was really close.
Yeah, that was really close.
Wait, do you guys get medals for family?
Yeah.
Did you?
Oh, yeah.
That would be awesome.
Nope.
Oh.
Not competitive enough.
I'm sorry.
Oh, good games, everybody.
Good games.
Yeah.
You guys, congrats on having the best family.
GG.
Thank you, guys.
See you guys.
Hello?
Hello, what are you doing up there?
I have to warm up for street fighter.
Why?
Warm up.
Not warm up.
Practice.
Sorry.
Because my coach is actually available.
Because he has a job.
Wait.
Why?
Were you trying to ask me to play Vallorant?
No.
You were trying...
You wanted to ask me to play?
You didn't play Valorant, didn't you?
No, I'm playing Minecraft right now.
I wanted to see if you wanted to look at my Minecraft.
Playing what?
What do you mean?
I wanted to see if you wanted to look at Minecraft a little and play on my server for a tiny bit for like a one day pass.
But like, I didn't know you didn't like me that much.
What do you mean?
That's guilt tripping.
I was offering a simple Minecraft.
You're like, you just want to play Valorant.
That's all you want to do?
Every time!
It's a pattern and you know it!
After, after...
You'd be like, Valorant!
But like, I wanted to show you how cute my house was.
You want...
It's a trap!
You wanted me to not practice Dream Fighters so tomorrow...
No, I'm not practicing either!
Wait, why aren't you practicing?
Wait, look.
I'm screen sharing.
Isn't this cute?
Oh, that's cute.
Also, chat, even if like, even if like, um, humans won in our lobby, Ellum's team would have still been first because they had three aliens.
Yeah.
Like, even if we had like, like, because it's like, what, three, um, Ellum's team would have still won.
So you don't want to play Minecraft?
I can't, Gumi.
I actually have to practice, Gumi.
We can play Minecraft after Street Fighter.
Promise?
Yeah, I promise.
We'll play Minecraft after Street Fighter.
I... I can't.
I... My coach... My coach is... is not a degenerate like me, so it's so hard to get coaching.
Ah, I see.
Okay, if you say so.
Alright, Gumi.
After Street Fighter, okay?
Or like, Saturday.
She called me.
Wait, do I have anything on Saturday?
Wait, weren't we supposed to do Saturday?
Yeah, we were, but then the Street Fighter shit happened.
So like, I can't.
Yeah, we need to decide on a date.
Uh...
Wait, decide what?
On a date.
To do the date.
Oh, the thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We will.
I just haven't had time to get the new date because of the Seijan Slam.
Yeah.
Alright, Gigi, Gumi.
Gigi, have fun in Minecraft.
Okay, baby.
Alright, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Thanks for the invite, Gumi.
Love you.
Bye-bye.
Stay back!
Alright.
Alright!
Welcome to the... We got that surprise stream, everybody.
We got the surprise stream.
I wasn't going to say.
But yeah, that was a crazy game.
I did not like the last game, I swear.
The last game was so fucked.
That was like, it was super fucked, I feel like, the last game.
Just because of the fact that like, it was, I feel like it was alien-sided.
I feel like it was alien-sided in general.
Like, even if I wasn't super suspicious, the game was heavily alien-sided, not huge.
Like, it was just... I had... I was sussing out, like, Peter and Tenzin.
But then I was like, this is a weird game.
It is weird.
It was... I was like, this is really difficult because you have to make three correct...
But like, yeah, but it's alright.
We got second place in the end.
We were in the lead.
Yeah.
Yeah, but then I was just naturally suspicious.
I feel like even if I wasn't naturally suspicious, I had no...
I felt like it was very difficult to figure it...
Like, have everybody unified in figuring out the three aliens.
But yeah, that was fun.
Thank you to Gumi for inviting me.
I had a really good time.
It was really fun interacting with everybody.
I'm really sorry if...
I'm really sorry if like...
If the sound balancing was really bad because my sound...
This was a super last minute stream and my sound guy was not awake at that time.
So...
I hope the audio balancing for...
Everybody was okay.
I know it wasn't perfect, but...
I hope it was decent.
Anyway, guys.
I had a great time.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Pause to check it up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
If you guys are new around here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on the YouTube.
But today, I am on Twitch because of Twitch Rivals.
So please check me out on the YouTubes.
And follow me on Twitter.
Because I usually talk about when I'm on Twitch.
I'm live on Twitter.
If you want to support me via other means, I do have other means of supporting.
Like the gamer subcode.
The Hyatt merch and everything.
The voice packs.
So check out my merch there.
And I want to see you guys later.
I need to feed my dog and walk him now.
Bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.